hello everyone and welcome back to the
saint louis rapid and blitz tournament
after some uh official random uh action
over the past few days now we go into
three days of rapid and two days of
blitz and we're starting off with a game
from round one hiko nakamura vs magnus
carlson
uh we didn't show the game he covered
versus magnus from the
uh official random uh tournament because
it was it was a bit of a snooze fest
but this one might not be a snooze fest
so we'll just check it out
and it's interesting that this
tournament uh regardless of it
not being any weird variant of chess
it's normal chess but if it's a tie
uh there's gonna be shared first place
uh with the prize money divided equally
and i think like even if like four
people share first place is going to be
a four people
tied for first place shared equally
money prize
uh event so just i thought i'd mention
that before we check out this game
uh but yeah this is the game from round
one so let's uh check it out hikaru with
the white pieces
opens with e4 magnus goes for c6 we have
the karo khan
d4 and d5 sorry about that
uh we have e5 magnus goes for the
advanced variation of the karo khan
and the bishop to f5 and now there are a
few
uh popular moves you could go for here
uh you could go for the immediate
g4 you could go for bishop to e2 you
could go for h4 you could go for
for a lot of things uh we have h for by
hikaru now preparing g4
which would force the bishop to go back
because this just uh
doesn't end well for the bishop so h5
magnus prevents g4 from hikaru and now
bishop to d3
and the magnus happily trades here with
captures captures and now that the light
square bishop is no longer
present e6 now which is very nice uh as
you can see all of his pawns are on
light squares
he has a dark square bishop which means
this is now a good bishop he can just
stroll freely through the pawns
bishop to g5 by hikaru attacking the
queen and the queen to a5
check we have knight to d2 blocking and
now queen a6
magnus says i want to trade queens and
i'm going to have a very very uh
fun time doing so and here while hikaru
could of course trade queens and allow
magnus to freely develop his knight he
goes c4
which is considered the strongest move
in this position and it is still
uh within within known theory knight to
e7 by magnus
now as uh all of these spawns nicely
control the light squares and this pawn
is already on h5
guarding against uh guarding against the
g4
uh the f5 will be an excellent outpost
for this knight so here
knight g2 f3 hikaru continues
development and
knight to f5 now putting putting some
pressure on the center of the board and
that knight here is a monster because it
will not be easy to get
to get rid of it at some point uh after
castles
this knight will probably come to f1 and
then the e3 or g3 to kick away the
knight from f5
we have castles by hikaru and now knight
to d7
and here there is one known game that
reached this position in 2015
uh yani pony she reached against libya
dieter nisi
it ended in a draw and the queen the c3
was played here by nepo
but here we have b3 by hikaru and it is
as of move 12 that we have a completely
new game
so magnus continues developing bishop to
b4 and now
rook f the d1 we have knight to b6
uh putting more pressure on the c4 pawn
and now rook eight to c1 adding another
defender so both of the rooks are now
nicely developed and
magnus finally castles and here knight
to f1 we said that
uh this is a an incredibly strong knight
so of course hikaru needs to kick it
away from their knight to f1
uh we have c5 by magnus uh magnus has a
very strong setup here and uh
while hikaru also has a very nice center
magnus can play c5 and attack the base
of hikaru's pawn chain here
and that's exactly what it is so c5
uh and now comes d captures on c5 uh we
have d
captures on c4 a nice in-between move
before capturing
on c5 and while hikaru could just
capture it there's no problem with
recapturing and going bishop captures on
c5 hikaru goes for a temporary pawn
sacrifice
or or maybe even even a permanent one
with queen to b1 and this is his idea he
wants to keep the queen
along this diagonal he wants to kick
away this uh uh this knight here and
then
create some mating threats so here
bishop captures on c5 and now
b4 they are kicking away uh carlson's
bishop
bishop to e7 carlson immediately offers
a trade of dark square bishops and now
well you could do this and it is fine to
do this captures captures in knight g5
threatening checkmate magnus plays g6
and it's a
it's a pretty sturdy position uh for uh
for white for example if you go
knight knight to g3 now you might be
having some plans of knight captures
here but you can just play rook
after d8 and it's uh uh it it is
playable but
it's hard to calculate everything that
happens here after this rook to d8 move
for example if you go knight captures on
h5 you're first going to capture on d1
with
check after real characters now you're
going to play knight to d
uh knight e to d5 and then uh
anything can happen you you guard the f6
square and even though uh
hikaru won this pawn it's not going to
be it's not going to be easy to continue
this but it is a
a very good uh a very good attack for
white however hikaru doesn't go for this
instead he goes knight to g3 he just
wants to clear this diagonal for his
queen
and of course he needs to get rid of the
the knight uh and also
he's just uh threatening to eliminate
one of the defenders of the bishop here
so here magnus trades
captures captures and now rook ate the
e8 adding more defense to the bishop
here
hikaru trades captures captures and now
knights to g5
again threatening checkmate and magnus
is forced to go
g6 and now uh again it's a very active
position for example
g4 looks like a very nice idea uh but
it's it's too slow it's uh because for
example if g4 captures an h5
seems like you're breaking through but
black is actually very happy knight to
d5 and the knight will be very useful
here
note if you capture here and captures
then the queen also guards the g6 square
so you haven't really achieved anything
you've actually added a defender
so for example after h captures on g6
now you go queen b6
check and after you move the king king
h2 let's say now king g7 and now it's
actually black who's attacking white and
not d not the other way around so here
after g6
queen to e4 he car centralizes the queen
and now he will have more support for
for the pushing of the pawns in the
future
uh and now knight to d5 by magnus he
says okay you can capture the pawn here
as okay now we're attacking it twice but
i'm gonna capture the pawn on a2
so here hikaru goes king to h1 a nice
prophylactic king to h1 maybe king to h2
uh could have been better as the king
will be
more safer there but it is hard to say
so king h1
now saying okay you can capture this
pawn here but capturing this
um uh pawn results in some very crazy
knight captures on e6 action because if
captures them captures on g6
and if you just recapture with the rook
then your knight is no longer defended
so here magnus doesn't
worry about that he just pushes c3 he
has a pass pawn so of course he wants to
advance it
and now comes rook to c2 blocking the
pawn and guarding the a2 pawn
you could also go for some g4 ideas here
right away
but again for example if captures h5
then black can just capture here and
even though you are very close to
breaking through
you're actually not going to be able to
do it because after h captures on g6
magnus successfully defends with f5 and
even though you have e captures an f6
alpha song
after knight captures uh or even rook
captures even better rook captures on f6
that
even attack the g6 spawn uh you don't
have much here rook c2 attacks the queen
like it'd be good if you you'd have rook
captures here captures and then you
could just pick up the rook the problem
is queen is guarding the d5 pawn so you
could try to kick away the queen
but queen b3 you're just going to keep
an eye on the knight and also put
pressure on the rooks here
so black will be black will be very
happy with correct play of course
black will be winning here so instead
hikaru goes to rook c2 he blocks the
pawn defends the a2 pawn
and now rook the c8 by magnus just
adding a rogue behind the pass pawn as
you should always do
and queen to f3 now now putting pressure
on this f7 pawn if the rook moves or
maybe you can add more attackers
queen to a4 by magnus now attacking uh
the rook on c2 and hikaru shifts it all
the way to f2 now the d1 rook is
defended
and also there's a triple attack on the
f7 pawn but
magnus goes c2 and he attacks the rook
here
and now of course you don't have time
for any captures on f7 so rook the c1
blocking it and now rook the c3 going
after the queen
but uh but but actually going for
something else as you'll see
and here hikaru goes for queen to e2
quinta e4
was probably uh better as it retains the
idea of knight captures than e6 with
with the same idea or if uh just rook
captures then you can capture the knight
but okay he went a queen to e2 instead
and now magnus just
grabs the pawn here queen captures on b4
and uh he also has some threats of
queen to b1 as the king is still on h1
so here
king to h2 but there's an even greater
trick here for black because why
wouldn't hikaru just capture the c2 pawn
and get rid of all of carlson's
pressure the problem is after rook
captures on c2
carlson has the incredible knight to e3
and now there's a problem yes you trade
the rooks and it seems like you've taken
care of everything
but how do you stop queen c1 there's
really not much you you do
you can do here because you will not be
able to block with the rook the knight
covers that
you cannot block with the queen the
queen covers that so all of these
squares are covered
and if you allow queen c1 check king h2
and knight g4
is is game over so you'd have to play
knight h3 to have some sort of a
coverage with knights to g1 but then
just rook d7
and now well rogue d1 is coming and even
if you defend with
knight to g1 then just knight to f5
knight the g3 is coming
and white is white is falling apart so
it is a
a completely losing move to go after the
pawn
so hikaru first goes king to h2 safety
first and then he's gonna grab the pawn
but now
uh magnus goes for for rook captures on
g3
and we've reached the position from the
thumbnail
so king captures on g3 otherwise you're
just
i mean getting uh getting destroyed and
now of course connecting with queen to
a3 this delivers check and also
attacks the undefended rook on c1 with
king to h2
and now queen captures on c1 so now
you've grabbed the pawn while also
traded some rooks and
white really doesn't have any ways of
breaking through so hikaru
uh could go for this end game but he's
down to pawns and it's just gonna be a
very slow and painful death for him
so instead he went queen to c4 he wants
to maybe
maybe throw in some queen to ca to check
who knows what can happen
but magnus says no problem rook c7
blocks the queen and queen to b5 now
again hoping for this
check maybe he can introduce a third
attacker to the f7 pawn
and then get some action going there
however it's completely losing position
now feel free to pause the video and uh
you know finish the game in great style
like magnus did
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for for those of you who are able
to do it congratulations on finishing
the game not just
in any way but in great style and for
those who just want to enjoy the show
it's of course
queen captures on g5 and this is what
magnus played and it was in this
position on move 34 that hikaru nakamura
resigned the game
and a round one uh game goes to magnus
so we'll see
what happens uh for the rest of the
tournament
so here of course you resign because
you've just lost a piece and once you
recapture the queen
black just gets another queen into the
game and that's just it queen eight
check is nothing here
because although you're attacking twice
you're also defending twice so it's not
a problem king g7 and
the pawn is nicely defended so there is
no counter play for white
you're done two pawns you're down the uh
down the knight i mean
completely completely winning for for
magnus
so uh that's uh the game i do hope you
enjoyed it sorry about
taking so long for me to cover it i
wasn't in my hometown had to arrive home
to cover it
so i do hope you enjoyed it uh i would
like to thank mohammed mohamed husseini
shai gross michael bartlett
musa alphabet and juan pablo barrera for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching
and i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the st louis rapid and blitz
event
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chest world so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day